gauthier qu'on termine journal le cadeau
que nous offre france roche et nos
cameramen tout sur la mode la mode de
l'été ce sont 18 bien sûr figurez vous
que pendant une semaine entière pour
2000 privilégier les couturiers vont
présenter 3000 robe qui valent 100
millions 1 milliard de centimes alors
bien sûr vous allez me dire c'est
beaucoup d'honneur pour seulement 4000
clients en france et dans le monde
eh bien je serais tenter de vous
répondre toujours à l'aide de
statistiques que cela fait vivre
trente mille personnes et que le chiffre
d'affaires est de 3 milliards et demi
c'est à dire le cinquième de la
sidérurgie
etonnant non alors fini de parler
chiffres maintenant parlons chiffon et
puis surtout regarde et écoute on trans
roche pour la petite dame qui vit le nez
en l'air perchée sur des talons
voici le tailleur de ferro toute rayure
en hauteur et plie bien plat
celui de torrents habasque courte et
cols sages canotiers dans le vent celui
de balmain dos décolleté et jupes
froncées
celui de chanel qu'on porte un gilet de
collégiens anglais et une cravate
western pour le petit l'ordre de jean
louis scherrer encore plus anglais
cannes et melon pour le soir les
écharpes fleuri de chanel
le pantalon surprise de patou qui
dénouerait devient unique et la tunique
biblique de cardin inscrits dans un
losange pour celle qui domine toutes les
situations romantisme exaspéré avec la
robe d'agip dansante devenait la manche
compliqué le corsage drapé de 30 à elle
la robe dit émotionnel de ferrou tout
froufrous et transparence
la robe lingerie devenait comporte la
même émotion as une robe ou une chemise
de nuit
hélas les dés de jean louis scherrer
avec basque et aumônière semble fait
pour une présentation à la cour
sultane brodé à trois étages par
givenchy
les falbalas violet de torrents tu
sembles fait pour une comtesse de
mourinho est toujours balzacienne se
lisent dans la vallée que fleury lapidus
enfin les jeux de longueur la robe cap
de pas tout
la robe duplex de balmain
et la mini longue de scapa rallye enfin
pour celles qui possèdent abondance de
charme
c'est la joie ampleur partout avec les
manteaux devenait exotiques ou de style
monacale dans ce tailleur de lapidus on
peut loger facilement une dame et demi
le tailleur de dior avec fermeture nous
et et jus boutonnet absorbe tous les
surplus
une autre trouvaille de dior la taille
plongeante devant pour estomac pas très
plat et aille encore plus basse chez guy
laroche avec ça on peut déjeuner
tranquille même confort chez perspect
avec ses manches oiseaux de ce qui
apparaît lit on peut donner de l'envol à
un éléphant dans la robe sans talent
d'ana et maury on peut loger des jumeaux
et dans ce tailleur de balmain des
quintuplés sans effort
avec la robe bébé de carven pas de
bourdes ni à la ville ni à la plage
enfin le soir en trompe l'oeil on peut
tout caché sous ses bus line août ont
montré
ainsi que dans ceux tard le qui n'a de
la roche
et dans cette robe abat-jour de nina
ricci
avec tout ça on portera des chaussures
lacées au pied et sur la tête des
boucles serrées que maurice francs que
veut appeler pour sa ligne
charlot et cinéma muet même boucle dans
la ligne bonsaï et cheveux les de lucie
sinclair ou écologiques comme
l'artichaut de michel maes tu es avec
colliers assorti de mini artichauts
enfin grand choix de pantalon loose ans
chez lanvin et resserré en bas indien
drapée aux chevilles chez hanae mori va
guincher ferrer
serré chez scapa really fendue au joli
chez cardin
en pleine inflation chez perse pau enfin
pour celles qui aiment se faire
remarquer 50 m de ficelle et 5 kg de
perles de bois pour copier cette robe
courants d'air de paco rabanne
l'année prochaine on peut en faire un
rideau andy mouche qui disait que la
haute couture n'était pas pratique
moi j'ai la coiffure un peu écologique